now this is being billed as the great
day of men out women in that is that the
choreography is quite clear I mean last
night was the night of the Long Knives
if you were em you know a middle-aged
man and today you've got this procession
of women's smiling as they go into
Downing Street and Isabel deep what's
your reading of this do you think that
this has been known as sort of a giant
leap forward for women in government
well I think number 10 office you want
to present it as a clearing out of the
men and ushering in of the women always
like this sort of jazz hands here come
the women basically but actually if you
look at who's been appointed so the new
foreign secretary is definitely a man
Michael Fallon has been promoted to
defense secretary he's quite manly to
Steven crab has replaced David James's
welsh secretary david james was psych
partly because he was a middle-aged man
stephen crabs a little bit younger but
he definitely got quite a big beard so
he's still a man so actually it's not
this great advance the women there are
women being promoted and I'm not going
to complain about women doing well in
their careers but some of them have shot
up through the party very very quickly
so Nicky Morgan was about venturing 2010
is now education secretary which is
still quite impressive so then there has
been advanced of women but it hasn't
been quite the kind of women domination
of the cabinet that we might have been
good leave me Nicky Morgan demonstrates
that the quickest way to get ahead in
this government is to get into George
Osborne's good books of course she's my
George's Angels as she went to the
Treasury and she's now and became you
know one of his ministers impressed him
became Minister for women when Maria
mother went and as now as now joined the
cameras
State Education one of the things I'm
surprised by I do me that the wise as
women's has to go women being
helicoptered in above our heads even as
we speak they don't know well of things
like what surprised by is it that the
promotions from women haven't quite um
justified some of the hype and so are
the headlines so we've not seen a daily
Cameron's not taking the opportunity to
appoint the first ever female defense
secretary we've seen what I think three
women join the full cabinet in Liz trust
going to environment Tina style from
need of Lords and Nicky Morgan education
none of these are kind of groundbreaking
roles an estimate vay who everyone was
tipping for the great fit for Ken clubs
old job she is just kept her Minister of
State drop for employment with the right
to attend cabinet which is really not
Batman services in other words the one
to say that she's been promoted the
cabinet when in fact she's doing what
she's only doing but I think it's very
what's very odd about that was there
seem to be allergic to putting on the
chemical otra which is she has very
marginal seat and freeing her up from
departmental responsibilities whilst it
allowing her to tour the broadcast years
and do all that stuff that seemed to
make a lot of sense so I'm slightly
surprised that they have decided to keep
her in a departmental job especially in
apartment DWP which is quite a lot of
work i also get impression david
slightly winched back from their
reshuffle for the women from the weekend
one of the few briefings they did give
to the Sunday papers was that there will
be a Tory first lady that was one of the
stories that appeared in the Sun now
there's no as far as I'm aware though
Tory first lady no special other than
the sound camera now ivan-san Kevin she
hasn't been berated yeah not yet it's
only to close but Sir James did you not
think I mean did something rather old
school and describing this and gender
terms I mean when we hit the spectator
all staff here are two thirds women
right we don't go out to hire people
because of their gender we just want the
best but there it seems as if your
gender is hugely important and it almost
seemed as if they see the gender first
and the person second I think what has
changed for the 2010 intake of torreón
pieces but there are lots of women in
there who deserve to be their own merit
I mean if you look back at some of the
people previously got into Tori cabinets
you could tell that was oh that was a
concern about gender balance when cheryl
gillan necessarily have been um well
secretary if she had been have been the
mail and peace ravilious yeah indeed and
there were actually won a female Tori
who has been promoting this reshuffle
she said to me recently but she thought
that it would actually quite a good sign
if Theresa videos or one of the other
women who have perceived have
underperformed would have left in this
reshuffle because it would have sent out
a message that this was actually about
merit but actually made things easier
for the women who are rising up the
ranks because it was a sent a clear
message that actually if women don't
perform their bed bound by exactly the
same rules as men and they get the older
they get the old heave-ho to this is
bill do you think futures how much the
butcher's care about gender balance and
I mean you know the idea is the party
wants to look like the rest of the
country and be modern etc I mean has
this been proven to get you more votes I
don't think we're going to see a post
reshuffle polling bounce amongst women
or anything like that but i suppose what
it does do is very subtly give the
impression as voters watch TV over the
next few months before the election that
there are women in government and i
suppose one of the things that swing
voters base their decision there in the
polling station on is whether they feel
the government represents them